with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense upbeat and entertaining straight
talking and direct we may act eight each
other and you thought-provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge now according to a
study released this week more than half
of Brits hate the sound of their own
voice thankfully not a problem that we
experienced around this table the same
study also found two-thirds of people
believe the way they speak has
negatively affected them at work
well at least rachel is proof that it's
not just how you speak but also how you
write that can affect your job maajid
I'll use the police are pandering to the
PC Brigade F WA acts as judge and jury I
promise to do my best
and Phil argues inclusion should be for
everyone but first Rachel shambles
shower abdication surrender some of the
kinder words for the Labour Party's
brexit policy or lack of to date given
its leaders have no desire to stay in
the EU but only want to topple treasom a
and enter Downing Street but is this
changing at conference this week labour
pledged to support all options remaining
on the table if the PM Steele gets
rejected including campaigning for a
public vote great but what would be on
the ballot paper on that labour can't
agree if there is to be a vote and it's
a big if the public cannot seriously be
asked to choose only between a bad deal
and no deal the party must grow a pair
and campaign for the option to remain in
the EU otherwise the public vote our
people's vote a second referendum call
it what you will would be a shocking
exercise in futility not democracy labor
has a constitutional duty as Her
Majesty's opposition to set out a clear
and distinct position if it doesn't it
is colluding in national self-harm right
you're right you I'm gonna go with
latias it's absolutely doing my nut in
this whole brexit thing I'm sick too the
tape of it the way I'm looking at this
thing myself right if I could break this
down and put it over to people to
deliver it in a way that they could
understand it would be like this alright
so in my household about Wendy alright
she's got the majority decision okay
she's the breaks it's here I've got me
kids all right they want to stay there
the levers all right but they've got
influence oh the remainders they've got
less influence of Wendy and they
certainly got the vote okay they've got
me I'm governed in the place at the
moment all right now
Wendy's saying to me come on Phil let's
get out here and the kids are so now can
we stay for a little bit at the moment
all the government are doing is trying
to pander to everybody and keep
everybody sweet the government exactly
have you said I've got to decide right
we've got to do something about it we've
got right now and we've got to get out
of here while we've got any credibility
because if I don't
Wendy's just gonna lose all faith and
all and all trust in me all together if
I don't go says that we have to execute
the result McNary's after almost one
vote that was taken over two years ago
and whatever the facts on the ground
have changed and whatever the deal that
comes onto the table is so if the facts
on that if the facts on the grounds have
changed it's because we've stalled them
we've begged for time and we've borrowed
and we've rob Peter to pay Paul we
haven't got on with what was gone
set out at the very beginning when that
vote was passed that we should leave
Europe when we decided that we were
going to drop that flag and pick up all
right okay we should have done that and
we shouldn't still be driving much
because we're not re running the
original referendum what we would be
doing if we do anything is to is to have
a look at there is a good deal which is
a different fate and I'm glad you caught
me because I feel just it's not the same
thing I thought you're it's important to
recognise this point that actually and I
spoke to Nigel Faraj about this and he
called it brexit in name only
if tourism owes cheque are still is what
we get even brexit ears don't believe
then it's good enough and so surely you
so back to your analogy with Wendy right
now if at the end of the day what Wendy
got wasn't leave but instead she just
got a house extension and and then she
was told to go and live in the
conservatory under the dictator still of
the person owns that house
Wendy still wouldn't be happy so surely
you'd want the public to have a say over
the terms of the deal that's reason a
brings back and if it's not hard enough
or breaks it for you or not good enough
to remain for us all of us surely would
want to say over those terms of brexit
and what is being given to us at the end
of the day last thing I'll say is what
you spoke of was the government's
position I think I believe what Rachel's
speaking of is the Labour Party's
position and I think at least they're
it's a national disgrace that Her
Majesty's opposition primarily because
it because of Jeremy Corbyn who's been a
brexit here for longer than I have been
alive unable to take a clear position on
this and you saw that at their logical
quick look so kiss Dharma shadow brexit
Secretary's statement on Labour's
position or what it should be it's right
that Parliament has the first say it's
right the Parliament has the first say
but if we need to break the impasse our
options must include campaigning for a
public vote and nobody is rolling out
remain as an option
yeah
we're do it together can we pass that a
little bit I think people get crossed at
the idea of a second referendum but why
don't we see if there has to be a vote
rather than a general election which
obviously the Tories aren't going to
vote for can we see this as a people's
veto on a bad deal instead of a second
vote I think the problem for me is I
think there's a lot to be said for
another vote because we don't know what
terms people signed up to and they vote
to break that but I'd your time now but
my issue is if you look at who is
backing a people's votes they're
massively pro-eu remain errs there is no
way that is gonna unify 80% of the
Labour Party
proteus my my view is the only way we
could have another vote that has any
credibility is if we can if brexit ears
are changing their minds I want to see
where the brexit ears are now concerned
about the directions is going which I
would imagine they are because it's a
complete shambles but the point is four
remain errs to be backing another vote
to brexit ears like we're trying to
subvert the democratic process and that
I worry about the consequences for our
democracy because brexit to me is a
symptom not a cause sure and stopping
brexit doesn't doesn't change the fact
that people voted for this because they
wanted to change and if people who voted
remain stopped that change I think it
would unleash something very worrying
and I just want to show you a statistic
about labour as well because I think
you're being a little bit unfair about
the labour party I agree I would have
loved to see labour come out strongly
backing remain and strongly laying down
an election or the conflict in the
initial referendum I would have liked to
see a much stronger support for remain
from labour and since the brexit vote I
would have liked to see labour doing a
better job of being the opposition
holding the government took out I've
been disappointed in the way in which
labor support but to be fair to the
labour party like every other party in
every other part society they're
completely divided and look at this
statistic sixty-one percent of labour
constituencies voted leave but only but
65 percent of labour voters voted remain
this is a party that is reflecting a
completely polarized base our country is
divided we're all divided and there is
just bring in the but but Labour Party
isn't divided if you look at the
statistics regarding the party
90% of labour members would vote remain
in a second referendum and 86 percent of
labour members were back a public vote
on the outcome of the negotiations and
what Labour voters are not kapo'i remain
they're divided before I get to me can
we just see Barry Gardner and please
tweet which basically explained why
labour has not done its duty as
opposition never interrupts your enemy
when they are making a mistake they are
just allowing the Tories to make a total
Horlicks of this so they think they can
stroll into Downing Street Nick I
thought you refer to it as a people's
vote so it will vote - two years ago was
it sheep donkey's vacuum cleaners to a
document that cost six five or six
million pounds that went through all our
houses why the government believes that
voting to remain in the European Union
is the best decision for the UK if you
please it's a once-in-a-generation to
suit not once every two years not once
when we decide that we don't quite like
it then let me quote directly this is
your decision the government will
implement what you just now hold on let
me finish will implement what you decide
that is the reality of it whether you
like it or whether you and can I just
say even when we were in Europe it
wasn't the land of milk and honey we
didn't get on particularly well on many
occasions it was a very fractious
relationship and I sometimes think when
I listen to you I like and respect and I
listen to you who I like in respect and
you who I know more than Britain I
thought we had a pretty sweet deal with
Europe and peace but going back to that
piece of paper not worth the paper it's
written on it's a leaflet Nick it was a
referendum it was an adventure the EU
with referendum bill says it was not in
the leaflet the winter every household
actually legal precedent to show that
political party promises are not legally
blind of the trajectory I take your
point however actually the trajectory is
headed in that way last year 31 percent
of people said they wanted another vote
on the terms of the deal this year it's
42 percent so people are changing their
mind the people in charge were now and
it's a state that nobody's coming to a
decision agreeable solution in the first
place time to do voters okay we would be
trying that and it simply hasn't been
working because